like we were talking about earlier
making a thing that you've had hundreds
of times before right I try to make
potentially hopefully the best version
of it what was an extraordinary crab
cake right how many crab cakes a million
million
so only Dungeness crab is used live
Dungeness crab is flown in every day
from the west coast at the bottom is a
mustard remoulade sauce pickled mustard
seed remoulade sauce and then these are
very very finely shingle potatoes that
that's formed the crust this is a work
of art there's no our there's no actual
breading in the crab it's just pure
crabmeat and then it's bound together by
the shingle potatoes and then the the
cutlery these are knives that are made
for us in Hawaii of Hawaiian Hawaiian
wood and grass look at my mouth is
watering do I get to taste this go ahead
this is incredible and then he's gonna
finish another dish for us over here
which is an old school old school
preparation
it's a pretty good cut and the potato
like a little bit of saltiness let's
keep it together
I'm trying not to just literally ignore
you now and keep eating this is
delicious dish we call filet Peconic so
tenderloin rub heavily in black pepper
and then it's finished with grilled
oysters so this this preparation is
actually traditionally called
carpetbagger we we named it Peconic
after the water that the oysters are
from and then it's just the white wine
butter sauce with the juices from the
grilled oysters and it's a sort of surf
and turf but a really elegant circuit oh
this is my dream just eating in a
kitchen like this first of all we can
just keep serving oh my gosh do you ever
have a moment when you're in here maybe
not with us but when you're just around
where you think how did I get here this
this is ours
yeah I mean I I'm IO I often sneak into
the into the dining room during dinner I
try to hide in the corner and I just
watch I'll just watch for five or ten
minutes
and it's pretty amazing thank you for
coming to my case anytime